[Music]
what is the significance of five players
being rated over 2700 it's absolutely
remarkable I remember maybe a few years
back we would be very fortunate just
have to 2,700 so to have five I mean I
didn't just I can't even imagine that I
think it shows that you know the United
States just seen is getting stronger and
stronger and also I think it shows a lot
of promise for the younger generation
because it means that we have a lot more
players to look up to in the future
it's definitely getting stronger year
after year is we're getting more and
more foreigners switching their
Federation's as well as more and more
Americans getting stronger so you know
last year was the strongest us
championship ever and then this year I
think is ten points stronger still so
the bar is just getting raised and
raised year after year and so it is it's
a really good opportunity for a players
like me I think who are not 2700 to play
against this popplers
it's a very strong tournament if Alex
beneath joke if not that's not qualified
for us championship so you know it's a
really big deal really having more
players at the top certainly makes it
harder to win because we're competing
against each other but I think the
difference is that it's strong from top
to bottom players for around 26 50 but
they are quite good very than yours very
talented and so it make it makes that
the tournament really really strong
because then it's it's I mean it's very
close to a super tournament I would say
even the Russian championship can't
really compete with that and an a linear
his playing for the US which is great I
mean he's a he's a top player and
husband for for many years so it's a
great addition both to to you guys chest
and to us championship it also makes it
a lot harder to win this tournament but
I I welcome the challenge yeah it's
completely different now with five
players over 2700 I could see by next
year or the year after we could have
maybe even two more players at least
over 2,700 by that time so yeah it's
really exciting I don't think it matters
really I mean it it does certainly does
but
you know once you take the tournament as
a whole it's just I mean you just have
to beat everybody or you know just go
after everybody I mean just the same way
you play another grandmaster